Hello and welcome to this video
Where we will show you all the wonderful things we have added
To Google Play Services 4.4.
As you now know, Google Play services are amazing.
This also means that when using Google Play services,
Oh, morning coffee.
Let's start right now.
Here are the key features of version 4.4.
New tools have been added to identify activities
To the API Locations interface.
Yaaah!
As for the Google Android Maps API we have attached
Some additions to indoor maps and - Shishsh.
That's true.
This is great and we will only reveal it later.
We've also added some new things to Play Games services
And Wallets.
We'll end this video with promotions
In-app for mobile apps.
Before we address this, let's start
With activity recognition tools in the API Locations interface.
As you know,
The possibility of detection has already been provided
Whether devices on a bicycle or car or fixed in place
Or slanted or moving.
Well, these are already many features.
But we decided to add more
We are pleased to offer two other activities:
Walking and running.
Thank you.
That's true.
We added walking and jogging to activity detection tools.
But we thought, why do not we have some bananas here
While experimenting with these things.
What am I doing now?
You're going.
That's true.
this is very good.
What am I doing now?
You run.
That's true.
this is very good.
Keep running.
This is good for your health.
What am I doing now?
You are driving a bicycle.
That's true.
this is very good.
No.
Do not stop running.
You are very close to the Googleplex.
Let me tell you.
It was tired and enjoyable,
Although this application was only experimental.
Imagine what your apps can do with this interface.
Let's take a look at the Google Maps Android API interface now
Let's start with the indoor maps where you can choose
Detecting decks when focusing on a new building
You will certainly discover the activity of the building
And the floor.
This is for example the second floor
From D Gates at San Francisco Airport.
Well, let us turn to - Ladies and Gentlemen,
That's right, we're going to announce something very important.
Let's add Street View to Google Maps Android API
With warm applause.
Go back to work.
Okay Sir.
You can now include Street View imagery in an activity,
Allowing your users to explore the world through panoramic views
360-degree control programmatically
Zoom in / Zoom in and the orientation of the Street View camera
And show camera movements.
Great, this is a great addition.
Imagine all these great additions and what you can do with your applications.
Now go to Play Games services.
We introduced in version 4.3 Game Gifts
Which allows you to order gifts or wishes.
Now, we're able to request a new API
So you can choose many game gift recipients.
In terms of games, this means the possibility of occurrence
More cooperation and social participation between players.
This takes us to the Wallet API interface
We added Wallet Fragments to the Instant Buy API.
Thanks to Wallet Fragments, it has become extremely easy
Merge the Buy with Google button into your app.
All you have to do is create and add these parts.
As a way to enjoy, see how shopping can be done
Now in just 10 seconds.
The user logs in to an application using Google Plus Sign-In and selects
Google Adjustable Bike to purchase them using
Buy with Google button to complete your purchase
Shipping to your home address.
And so on.
You buy a bike in 10 seconds.
Let's end by talking about mobile ads where we've added
In-app promotions.
This is an API that allows publishers
View in-app promotions
Enabling users to purchase goods
Advertised directly within the app.
By these plugins, users can buy products that
They are easily charged, as advertisers can
Access to consumers The application is able to understand communications.
No one is a loser.
We got to the end of the video however
Stay connected because we will announce more.
Now it's your turn to start up and create great apps.
And do not forget to tell us everything about your experience.
Oooh!
Be more careful
When climbing.